and it's day 373 of Vladimir Putin's
10-day special military operation and
there's been activity across the whole
of the front line in particular around
the Donetsk area
um the Russians have been trying to
attack to the north and south of Donetsk
and then further up in the north
um in the criminal area and of course
bakmut which we'll I'll talk about more
in a moment the Russians have also been
attacking a civilian infrastructure in
the Ukrainian held area of the Donetsk
oblusk and last night there were 38
attacks from artillery
um or missiles but also yesterday we
have seen a visit allegedly into the
donets career by the Russian defense
minister the Russian mod have put out
some pictures of him walking around some
of the
um destroyed towns and handing out
Awards to Russian soldiers however we
haven't been able to geo-reference this
particular footage and the last time
shogu came and was allegedly at the
front line it was filmed somewhere else
but it's all part of the Russian
information campaign or the
disinformation campaign that they're
putting out trying to encourage the
soldiers and for the battles that
they've got ahead by focusing into
backwood the Russians are increasing
their circling from the north and coming
in from the East and the pressure is
growing through the city but that
pressure's been growing for the last
seven plus months and for that seven
months the ukrainians have been fixing
the Russians in place and they've been
according to the Ukrainian Minister of
Defense killing seven Russians for
everyone Ukrainian Casualty that there's
been however it is only a matter of time
before that pincer squeezes back mood to
the point where the ukrainians feel that
they have to withdraw and trade space
for time
um they would have pre-prepared further
blocking positions on defensive
positions further back
um and I don't really see it as being a
victory for the Russians it's taken them
so long to take somewhere that um hasn't
got any real strategic significance
moving on further when we start to look
at the global impacts of this we've got
the Russian foreign minister lavrov has
been finishing off at the end of the G20
with some meetings in India and at his
latest one yesterday he tried to say
that the war in Ukraine is a war which
we tried to stop as it was launched
against us by the West using Ukrainian
people the reaction of the Indian
audience was one of laughter now the
world is splitting into two real
sections here an element that is not
condemning Russia and that's China India
Pakistan Iran and a number of others and
then the Western aligned countries
um that are back in Ukraine and Russia
is exploiting that by turning around
saying that the impact that is happening
on a global basis is because of the
sanctions against Russia rather than
Russia's war on Ukraine and that impact
is having is is being felt globally
especially with grain and cooking oil in
particular in the third world countries
but we felt it with the energy crisis
that there's been throughout Europe and
the rest of the West